[Music]
in certain quarters cynicism has a
distinct kind of glamour
it sounds pretty tough not to have too
many hopes and to claim to be able to
see through the dreams of others cynics
will tell you that everyone is selfish
and weak that the system is rigged and
driven by greed that you can never
succeed so it's pointless and
contemptible to try that all ideals are
ridiculous and the do-gooders are only
out to show off their own supposed
virtues it's lupus to try to disprove
cynicism there will always be an
abundance of vivid examples to back up a
catastrophic interpretation of humanity
but what identifies people as cynics is
not so much what they claim as why they
do so that downbeat assessments are
based not on a dispassionate analysis of
our species but on an inner emotional
compulsion their philosophy is first and
foremost a defense against suffering
beneath that gruff surface cynics are
afflicted by a near hysterical fragility
around the idea of expecting anything
which turns out to be less impressive
than they'd hoped
and so they twist their mental apparatus
to secure themselves against the
eventualities of any discouragement they
disappoint themselves before the world
can ever do it for them at a time and in
a manner of its own choosing cynics may
look like people trying very hard to see
the facts as they are but in truth they
are trying even harder to insulate
themselves against pain the origin of
their stance is not worldly experience
an insight
it is rather more poignant Lee
psychological trauma somewhere in the
past they will probably have been a blow
to their hopes that felt too powerful to
handle sadly though cynics don't give
away the slightest clue as to their
touching and vulnerable backstories they
will instead talk stridently about
corruption and manipulation pile up
ample
samples of greed and profit complex
sounding theories about economics but
what they won't do is voluntarily or
easily reveal how their father
humiliated them when he was drunk or how
it felt when their mother ran away to
another city when they which is five the
cynic
is never truly and completely cynical
they are still recovering from hopes
that grew too painful to avow a natural
temptation when encountering a cynic is
to try to argue them out of their
attitude by citing counter examples but
this is in its own way crow because it
misunderstands what cynicism is about it
is an emotional protection in essence a
mode of coping learned under conditions
of duress what the cynic really needs
and yet fears they may never get so
naturally never asks for his kindness a
kindness that may eventually help them
to rekindle their stunted secret desires
over hope and fulfillment
you